[Music]
you can predict the future
people believe i can
and they don't like the future i predict
foundation is the greatest science
fiction work of all time
and it's never been brought to the
screen before
it was such a phenomenal influence on
the star wars universe
even things like dune were influenced by
foundation
the might of the imperium has brought
peace to thousands of worlds
it's a story of ideas and they are bold
ideas
on one side you've got the genetic
dynasty the
empire
and the other side there's harry selden
in a thousand-year chess game in order
to save a galaxy
change is frightening
especially to those in power
it's epic it's epic in its ambition it's
epic in its storytelling it's a
thousand-year tale
the trick was figuring out how to take
these weighty ideas that span a
millennia and make them emotional
[Music]
i risk my life coming here
you made a choice
the story expands in such a huge way
there's so much in every episode there's
fighting and hatred and love
it just speaks to the human experience
and empathy and
power the size and ambition of the show
is massive
and it's fantastic
it took a while for the world to be
ready for foundation
and that age has finally arrived
you came here hoping to save your world
i'm asking you to dream bigger
only weekend short of the darkness
[Music]
you